vous à présent pascale joannin bonjour
notre invité du jour vous êtes
directrice générale de la fondation
robert schuman c'est assez intéressant
ce que nous dit la pauvre gogo un jeu
diplomatique assez surprenant finalement
les russes qui se tournent davantage
vers vers les américains qui al'avantage
aujourd'hui selon vous dans cette crise
on voit bien cette volonté de l'union
européenne des européens aujourd'hui de
se faire entendre de moscou d'où ce
drapeau des sanctions qui va être agité
ce soir est-ce que ça va fonctionner ou
pas c'est la leur sur l'union européenne
un effet et le voisin de vallet maire
faut-il il ne le respecte pas ils ne
l'aiment pas et il fera tout pour que il
fait tout pour que diviser les européens
il considère l'allemagne considèrent la
france et considèrent un peu le royaume
uni mais on n'est plus dans l'union
européenne et il a perdu beaucoup de sa
superbe depuis 30 ans donc le retour
comme le dit votre correspondant à un
dialogue avec les états unis c'est
essayer de revenir un espèce de duo paul
dans lequel il était au centre du jeu
maintenant le duo paul c'est plutôt
chine etats unis et il joue j'allais
dire une partition un peu bizarre
puisque on sait très bien que les états
unis sont en train de se retirer
progressivement après l'afghanistan
ils rient se tournent plutôt vers l'asie
donc l'europe s'est pas vraiment leur
leur carte maîtresse est donc là dernier
poutine essai de bail passé sur les arts
op 1 et les européens lui rappelle que
maintenant à l'union européenne n'est
plus ce qu'elle était quand il y avait
la guerre froide elle est plus divisée
elle est plus forte elle a des
compétences il ya des choses qui
n'existaient pas et donc avoir faire
avec et donc ils essayent de lui tordre
un peu le bras en disant on sait que
vous avez mis des hommes donc et une
intention de nuire cent mille hommes
quand même senti l'âme à soi même
peut-être même 150 mille d'après
certains services de renseignement donc
c'est une intention qui n'est pas acquis
et belliqueuse quand même donc et donc
nous on n'acceptera pas que vous
engagiez ce conflit alors on n'est pas
une puissance militaire c'est vrai mais
on est une puissance économique beaucoup
plus forte que ne l'est le la russie est
donc on va être on vous a déjà tendu un
peu le bras économique ça fait mal et
donc on vous fera encore plus mal si
vous vous mettez dans la position
d'envahir c'est ça notre principal atout
c'est pas là tout parce qu'on n'a pas
décidé et personne ni les états unis ni
l'europe de faire la guerre voilà alors
bon on essaye de cette période
diplomatique de dire c'est un jeu vous
savez si tu fais ça un bras de fer
d'écologique un bras de fer
psychologique on disait en essayant de
détail d'arriver à une désescalade est
de faire en sorte que le la volonté la
décision politique peut prendre seul le
président poutine dont pas d'engager le
conflit de ces hommes qui sont massés à
la frontière ne se prennent pas alors il
ya plusieurs moyens de rétention il ya
les sanctions économiques de l'union
mais il ya des projets qui sont entrain
pays l'allemagne et la russie le fameux
projet north stream ii qui est quasiment
en voie de alors l'allemagne n'a rien
dit mais les américains puisque on leur
demande leur parole là ils disent ah bah
si vous faites pas si tu joue au con et
si tu joue avec le feu nous on a moyen
de rétorsion c'est que tonton gazoduc là
qui te ra permettrait de faire du
business etc eh bien il s'ouvrira pas
comme ça va tu auras pas voilà le coeur
plein de charme arguments qui parle
effectivement à l'oreille de vladimir
poutine et fédéraux russes blessure
parce que cette grande richesse russell
elles proviendront des hydrocarbures et
l'économie russe en ce moment ne va pas
très bien l'état sanitaire est
déplorable mais ils sont il sait ça va
pas donc si on leur option le sillon
lieu prive de contrat qui lui permettent
de vendre un petit peu ces hydrocarbures
il va se retrouver coincé à la corde il
ya peut être une opinion publique russe
qui est va lui dire mais enfin bon c'est
bien gentil tout ça mais pour quel pour
quel résultat on va gagner quoi avoir
tout le monde contre nous alors j'ai
bien que ben la dernière pour teen en
même temps qu'il part à l'achat la
russie essaie de dégager un petit peu
son flanc oriental en essayant de jouer
il ya eu des discours avec
vim et c'est une ligne la plus soutenue
que mais c'est pas lui non plus qui va
faire un jeu
d'intervention donc vraiment la carte et
en europe et il faut que dans l'animé
routine comprennent que il y aura à une
vraie riposte et la france et
l'allemagne plus les autres vont essayer
d'apporter des sanctions supplémentaires
si on a déjà depuis 2014 année alors
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites la
france l allemagne et les autres vous
évoquez l'un des enjeux de cette crise
tentatives de déstabilisation des
européens division créée tentative de
diviser les européens entre on sait que
ça peut être extrêmement facile sur
certains dossiers on l'a vu encore
récemment est-ce que vous pensez que
l'europe peut serrer les coudes face à
la russie alors l'europe doit serrer les
coudes alors est ce qu'elle veut elle
peut le faire parce que en c1 le mans
est idéal parce qu on a un nouveau
chancelier un nouveau gouvernement en
allemagne
on attend encore et on n'a pas encore
les élections en france donc le
président français est encore là
vladimir poutine a toujours joué sur le
le timing à la géorgie c'était au mois
d'août là on peut se dire qu'il ya une
période de fêtes qui arrive dans une
période charnière landrier des fêtes
orthodoxes russes n'est pas celui des
fêtes chrétiennes
occidentale et donc il peut jouer en 10
ans mais solde vient d'arriver il n'est
pas assez puissant et maquereau est en
fin de mandat donc jeu mais voilà et
donc là il ya quand même le fait que les
deux qui sont dans le format dans m'ont
dit c'est pour ça que j'en parle format
normandie c'est la france l'allemagne
l'ukraine et la russie sont là et
visiblement en europe aujourd'hui en
tout cas
ursula von der leyen charles michel qui
use josep borrell sont sur la même ligne
et ils sont soutenus par des pays comme
les pays baltes la pologne et la suède
qui veulent en effet une réponse forte
face à
la russie donc il ya plutôt une majorité
et donc je pense pas que pour l'instant
poutine et compris que la fissure aller
là on va les spéciaux ils sont plutôt
dans le genre on discute mais on a des
moyens certes limité mais des moyens qui
pourraient vous faire mal si jamais vous
mettez vous appuyez sur le bouton rouge
et une volonté surtout si je vous suis
bien l'europe qui a fort à faire en ce
moment en même temps c'est pas c'est pas
la seule puisque ce matin il était
question de la crise sanitaire au mieux
ron sûr cela van der leyen a dit hier
c'est invariant qui se propage
extrêmement rapidement qui pourra
devenir dominants d'ici la mi-janvier ça
c'est l'une des préoccupations numéro
une des européens aujourd'hui gelée dire
internationale parce qu'on voit bien que
ce variant omicron il est partout il est
donc en mai en europe en ce qui nous
concerne sont en effet voir comment on
peut
m à essayer de faire que la pandémie
soit pas aussi grande que ça donc il ya
la question des vaccins et on voit bien
aujourd'hui que les états sont très
prudents parce que le vaccin on sait
qu'il était bon sur certains types de
virus peut être pas sur celui ci le
variant delta mais pas sûr sur le dragon
mikron est donc on voit de plus en plus
en europe en tout cas à côté du pass
sanitaire qui avait été mise en place au
mois de juillet et c'est la volonté de
revenir à une sécurité supplémentaire
dans les échanges alors c'est vrai c'est
valable pour tous mais où en dehors à
côté de se passer ni terre on vous
demande un test supplémentaire pour
annie sûr que vous soyez bien négatif au
moment où vous entrez dans un pays pour
éviter que il ya des nouveaux foyers de
dissémination du virus le problème
justement c'est que ça se faire en ordre
dispersé et pas de façon coordonnée
c'est un peu lent je vais le faire avec
ça et puis en effet ce qu'on aura le
nombre de vaccins suffisant pour faire
ce troisième rappel et puis le vaccin
pour les enfants qu'ils soient acceptés
par les populations et puis les antilles
vax qui sont encore suffisamment
virulent on a vu en allemagne se
radicalise qui se radicalise merci
beaucoup pascal janin ça fait beaucoup
de dossiers puis on aura l'occasion de
se retrouver à la rentrée après les
fêtes parce qu'elles aboutissent à une
présidence faisait beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de choses à dire merci vous
étiez notre invité du